following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at
vault-tec have prepared these
educational materials for you to better
understand the seven defining attributes
that make you special today we will
focus on strength in the wasteland
essential supplies will be scarce when
an item of value is found keep it close
and away from bullies the stronger you
are the more you can carry be sure to
know your limits where you may find it
challenging to escape from hazardous
scenarios no matter how strong you are
there are other situations where you may
find yourself in close proximity to
unfriendly neighbors for such cases you
must learn to defend yourself using your
natural strengths use anything sharp or
sturdy enough to swing get creative with
your implement but stay reasonable
and for anything that can further
enhance your innate vigor the greater
your strength the greater the impact but
remember some moments require more than
muscle keep doing your chin ups and push
ups because there's more strength can do
for you swing for the fences like the
pros crafting specialized protective
gear to keep your building clever
weapons to wield it regularly study your
vault tech provided materials to prepare
for survival and to answer the question
do you know what makes you special
following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at
vault-tec have prepared these
educational materials for you to better
understand the seven defining attributes
that make you special in this chapter we
focus on perception it is the
unfortunate truth that when you go above
ground you will be faced with many
post-nuclear nuisances these frightening
menaces will come in all different
shapes and sizes and pose an immediate
threat to your survival you must learn
to deal with these dangers but may find
this challenging at first
that's why we've provided you with the
vault-tec assistance targeting system so
you can scan the threat and pinpoint
areas of weakness and the higher your
perception the more accurate you will be
why you'll put Davy Crockett to shame
there may be times when you must engage
in questionable activities your
perception can help keep you safe during
these morally ambiguous moments practice
your pilfering on youths the elderly or
the incapacitated
as you continue to purloin your way to
success try more challenging targets and
more skillful techniques for greater
returns
don't get too cocky there sport
always look to sharpen your five senses
for perception doesn't stop there keenly
assessing the unfriendly locals and
Tareq handling sensitive munitions with
people in building a long-distance
relationship regularly study your
vault-tec provided materials to prepare
for surviving and to answer the question
do you know what makes you special
following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at
vault-tec have prepared these
educational materials for you to better
understand seven defining attributes
that make you special our topic today is
endurance we will all be faced with many
new and unfamiliar health risks such as
infection sudden loss of limb and above
all harmful radiation fortunately your
formidable endurance has turned your
body into a hard-working machine that
can resist the harmful effects of
radiation and physical violence like any
machine then your body must be
well-maintained to stay in tip-top shape
while average joes will survive on old
packaged standbys your ironclad insides
will allow you to seek fresh meat
radiation poisoning may have enlarged
your favorite meals
this means more healthful nutrition for
you take caution not to bite off more
than you can chew endurance can also
provide new options for food some of
which can be an acquired taste
gone are the days of exercising for fun
instead you will need to combine
athletics with crucial survival
activities the greater your endurance
the further you can go just be certain
to be mindful of others build your
endurance and soon you will find ways
that it improves your life above ground
added confidence in the swimming pool
stronger more resilient limbs to cross
the flesh of your fellow man can provoke
regularly study your vault-tec provided
materials to prepare for survival and to
answer the question do you know what
makes you special
following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at
vault-tec have prepared these
educational materials for you to better
understand the seven defining attributes
that make you special
and now charisma what is it made of
unlike the clean wholesome America you
may recall the wasteland will be a
distrustful place full of unsavory
characters and a few more E's earning
the trust of your fellow man is an often
overlooked key to survival one way to
prove your trustworthiness is through
fair commercial exchange your renowned
charisma will enable more favorable
bartering don't get greedy now use your
charismatic nature to negotiate your way
out of tense moments having friends is
always of value how else do I find
friends you may wonder you may find an
impromptu cocktail hour helps to ease
social stress your charisma will help
you avoid the perils of addiction but
not the immediate effects of drink so
practice moderation or you'll find out
who your real friends are the hard way
you will find that even wild animals can
be charmed by your charisma looks like
you found a new pal
awful don't get carried away there big
fella
so you see taking the charismatic
approach is more than just good manners
working with man's best friend into more
loyal companions with Vinson others to
act on your behalf
regularly study your vault-tec provided
materials to prepare for survival
and to answer the question do you know
what makes you special
following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at
vault-tec have prepared these
educational materials for you to better
understand the seven defining attributes
that make you special
our next area of attention is
intelligence with all the talk of
physical survival in the wasteland you
may forget that sometimes it's survival
of the smartest an empty mind is a
vessel for knowledge and intelligence is
the key to unlocking opportunity and
adapting to your new world above ground
your advanced know-how will grant you
access to new places and new
technologies space age isn't it
intelligence survivors are also more
inventive creating technological wonders
of their own
note that the s in science stands for
safety and when the tables are turned
against you don't be afraid to set aside
your refined intelligence for the raw
instincts of survival just don't lose
your head
advanced learning in the field of
intelligence can offer even more
benefits in this modern age of wonder to
start navigating with technological ease
keep blood where it belongs by helix in
creating more potent chemical compounds
from regularly study your vault-tec
provided materials to prepare for
survival and to answer the question do
you know what makes you special
following Vogel's atomic annihilation
the rebuilding of this great nation of
ours may fall to you that's why we and
vault-tec have prepared these
educational materials for you to better
understand the seven defining attributes
that make you special
now let's discuss the uses of agility a
nuclear blast and the subsequent fallout
will have many adverse effects on life
as we know it intensive prolonged
radiation exposure may transform those
above ground into decrepit rotting
beings that have lost their ability to
reason they will likely be without
common manners and quick to anger you
must learn to make the most of available
firearms but enthusiasm will only take
you so far
now let's try that again and remember
that with your impressive agility you
can act more decisively in glance see
it's a snap
agility can also help you out in
difficult moments
but why place yourself under undue
stress instead try a subtler route
taking the quieter approach is always
worth consideration your agility can
turn a sneak attack into a complete
tactical move
keep in mind others may have the same
bright idea your agility will help you
move through the wasteland with ease and
yield other benefits like assaulting an
unsuspecting dreamer for they can
hastily reloading your firearms by
piling on damage to additional targets
when the regularly study your vault-tec
provided materials to prepare for
survival and to answer the question do
you know what makes you special
following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at
vault-tec have prepared these
educational materials for you to better
understand seven defining attributes
that make you special got your rabbit's
foot good it's time we talk about luck
the difference between whether you live
or die
in the post nuclear world may depend on
the flip of a coin luck is a mysterious
sort of curiosity see here the
well-placed shot may not always do the
trick if Lady Luck favors you though
you'll find those critical moments a
breeze what's this
only scrounging up duds time and
patience may net you a suitable
collection but with luck on your side
you're bound to find some swell keepers
no no hold on to anything shiny it may
be of hidden value be careful not to get
distracted by your newfound fortunes
although that wasn't the only test it
looks like luck has helped you once
again unfortunately she can't save you
from every situation at least your
misfortune can become someone else's
fortune
luck may be fickle but if you can loo
her to your side the possibilities are
endless a particularly bloody mess will
lift the chance to build a streak of
destruction that comes the magic of the
unexpected all regularly study you want
tech provided materials to prepare for
survival and to answer the question do
you know what makes you special